what is the will to risk what is the
will to risk somebody asked me
do you think anyone can be funny
and I said I think anyone can be funny
I'm not sure everyone is willing to risk
being funny because the will to risk
implies the will to fail if I try this
and it doesn't work there will be
consequences if my fear of consequence
is quite great then my will to risk is
quite low because the the fear of
negative consequences bad outcomes will
keep me from Taking Chances as an
example you might be terribly funny
and you might want to do stand-up comedy
but you have to have the will to risk to
get from the floor to the stage even if
it's only six inches that's a big step
up and the only way you can take that
step is if you can bring your mind
around to the idea that this outcome
doesn't matter it might be a bad outcome
it might hurt me emotionally
but for the sake of my goals it's a step
I have to take
and that the whole math of it is if you
have a clear sense of your goals and you
can link those goals to actions then the
combination of goal and action will give
you the will to risk because you will
see quite clearly in order to achieve
this goal I have to take this action I
understand that there's a risk of a
possible negative outcome but I also
understand that if I don't take this
action I can't achieve that goal and
that's a known bad outcome
so I fight against
theoretical or possible bad outcomes
with the knowledge that taking no action
is itself an undesirable outcome for me
it won't advance me toward my goals
do you think some people have a natural
just sort of like the a propensity to be
up in front of a crowd it doesn't if
they fail if someone throws a tomato at
them it's not the end of the world
I think some people have that quality
naturally some people acquire it a lot
of us are I don't want to say that we're
programmed in our youth but I'll just
tell you about my own experience as a
youngest child youngest of three I was
counted on to be funny
you know it's the little one I was the
cute one and there was a lot of positive
reinforcement directed at me for taking
comic risks
as a consequence I grew up feeling
pretty comfortable with taking not just
comic risks but creative risks of all
kinds mostly because I had already
acquired some experience in trying some
things that work and trying some things
that don't work in my book the comic
toolbox and this is kind of one of the
things that I'm known for I I establish
What's called the rule of nine which
says says for every 10 jokes you try
nine won't work and you think well
that's a terrible bad average I'm only
getting it right one time out of ten
that's horrible it's not because it
tells you two important things one is
you're gonna get it wrong much more
often than you get it right getting it
wrong is the norm and the other thing is
if you have 10 jokes
and you only need one to work then you
don't have to invest a hundred percent
of your ego in any one joke you can
basically distribute all of your ego
across 10 jokes and any joke that fails
only costs you ten percent of ego and
then that one joke that does work that's
what you need to advance toward your
goals and anytime you advance toward
your goals your ego feels much better
so we can say what falls out from this
is for someone who's operating in
Creative spaces we're always operating
in an ego space we're always
engaged with whether we know it or not
engage with the question of how does
this circumstance make me feel
what I try to do is focus on a different
question how can I use this circumstance
to advance toward my goals I find that
if I operate with that question in mind
the fear Falls away the insecurity Falls
away the the
um
uh the will to risk advances because
it's clear that no matter what's going
to happen I'm going to gather
information and it's going to advance me
toward my goals one way or another
so
the ultimate outcome of this is
I'm going to do a better job I'm going
to create better products I'm going to
win more acclaim
and it turns out
from moment to moment as writers or
creators we are uh serving our ego
and the minute we stop serving our ego
and serve the work instead try to make
the work as good as it can be
then the work becomes better and better
and better we achieve more we attain
more
and our ego feels that much better all
of which boils down to to serve the ego
ignore the ego and save your ego for the
award ceremony hahaha
but you know they say that most people
fear uh the biggest fear is public
speaking I'd rather stand up in front of
a group of people on a topic I know
nothing about and be booed off the stage
then let's say walk across the Golden
Gate Bridge on a windy day which I've
done in a class trip and couldn't make
it so some people have certain fears
that that seem normal and you know
public speaking I guess is considered a
normal fear I I use a
metaphorical structure for my fears I
imagine that the inside of my brain is
outer space and my fears are present in
here and there in outer space they
manifest as black holes they suck all my
energy and they they warp reality they
do a lot of bad things and since they're
black holes they feel dangerous to me so
I avoid them fear is fear of rejection
let's say as an example or in my case
fear of not hearing adequately so my
experience of this is if there's a black
hole that exists and I don't confront it
then it exists and it dominates but if
there's a black hole that exists and I
confront it doing no more than saying I
acknowledge this black hole I
acknowledge the presence of this fear
that kind of sucks the air out of that
balloon the black hole goes away and I
have more freedom of movement in my own
mind that's why I use that metaphor and
that's what I'm attempting to serve not
to deny my fears or even really make
them go away just to acknowledge their
presence and manage them effectively as
part of my overall job of being as
successful or creative on entrepreneur
as I can
what if a writer is afraid they will
embarrass themselves and maybe
especially embarrass themselves in front
of a group of their peers
strangers it's like whatever but yeah
strangers is like whatever but oh my
mom's in the audience
or March from accounting well
it's Marge from the county
I'm going to answer your question but
first I'm going to go around about a
little bit of story
I was in Prague in the Czech Republic
doing a comedy writing Workshop
and it was a multi-day thing and I was
just getting started I was midway
through the morning on the first day
and I'm at a point in my lecture and I
just lose it might have been jet lag
might have been I don't know something
that I thought I understood very well I
suddenly couldn't make head and her tail
stuff it was a story structure
and I was trying to communicate and I
just found that I couldn't and I had a
kind of a freak out moment and I it
wasn't bad and I acknowledged I said to
the audience so you guys let's take five
minutes I've lost the plot I need to
find it again and that was the moment
and we took a break and I came back and
started teaching something else
tonight
we went the whole group went out for
drinks and dinner and my wife was there
she was traveling with me and she was
part of the party and later she reported
to me that she talked to a lot of
different students and they all said the
same thing that moment when he fell
apart and acknowledged that he'd Fallen
apart
that's when he won our Allegiance
because we thought if that guy can fail
this expert can stand in front of us and
fail so visibly and own it and transcend
it and move on that's a big relief to us
because now we're not afraid of failure
we've seen the boss failing we've seen
the Maestro failing that leaves us free
to manifest our own failure
I have since used that
over and over again as a strategy if the
room is tough if people are feeling
uptight they're not ready to take
chances yet I just fail I fail on
purpose I go someplace crazy I go out on
a limb that I know I'm not going to
arrive someplace good and just
crash on on purpose so that people can
see me modeling failure and feel better
about their own failure now back to your
question can you repeat it please
because I was uh tell me tell me again
the questions you asked is a writer
afraid they will embarrass themselves
and embarrass themselves in front of a
group of their peers okay to be writer's
room okay so there I am embarrassing
myself in front of a group of students
each of them is worried about
embarrassing themselves in front of
their peers it's a comedy writing
Workshop they're supposed to be funny
Stakes are high pressure is high they're
not going to do well I'm going to
instruct them to lower pressure by
embracing failure I always tell people
in these circumstances if you must fail
and you will fail fail big if you have a
magnificent failure at least you created
something that was magnificent and if
your goal is to fail big then failure
doesn't scare you anymore but in terms
of
this idea of I'm afraid of the negative
response to the people around me I think
a lot of that is
what I call cartoon emotion we have
emotional states that exist without
giving too much thought to them and the
emotional state we're in right now is
people are going to hate me people who
love me will hate me that's on on on the
on the Bedrock that's what we're afraid
of if I if I write this romantic novel
if I write this screenplay if I do this
stand-up comedy routine and it goes bad
which it will because I'm a loser then
everybody who loves me will hate me I'll
be that much more of a loser we can see
that this is a lot of kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy toward a
negative outcome a vicious circle we can
turn it into a virtuous circle simply by
saying I'm going to have this experience
and I'm going to collect this outcome
I'm not going to have expectations on
whether it's going to be a good outcome
or a bad outcome try for a good one but
not
marry my ego to a good outcome
and what's going to help me in this is
the understanding that people who love
me actually love me they're rooting for
a good outcome and if it happens that I
don't get a good outcome the only one
it'll really bother is me because I'll
feel like I'll let them down they're
prepared to give me charity they're not
going to condemn me for trying something
that didn't work out they're on my side
so in the moment where I am attempting a
creative act trying to throw it out the
window and see if it lands I need to
remind myself the audience is not in
conflict with me they want the same
thing I want a good outcome a a funny
joke a good story a good movie
experience whatever we're all on the
same side we're not against each other
and that also will help me step over
that fear barrier and into the
experience that I want to have
so if someone would like to win the
empathy or the sympathy of a crowd
should they knock the microphone off the
podium for a second and then apologize
or drop their papers it's a perfectly
valid strategy I've seen stand-up comics
trip getting up on stage it never fails
to get a laugh because of what we talked
about slipping on a banana peel in a
sense making yourself the Target in a
sense this is stand-up comedy 101 make
yourself the Target in my book the
little book of stand up I talk about
your first five minutes what are you
trying to do with that precious first
five minutes of comic material that you
trying to generate one thing you're
trying to do is Define yourself another
thing you're trying to do is to build
audience Allegiance and you can do both
of those things by telling jokes about
yourself that matter
I might say look at me I haven't had a
bad hair day in 25 years
and it's my way of saying I'm bald
everybody knows you're bald I don't
carry any issues with me about baldness
but I could certainly use the appearance
of having those issues to win audience
Allegiance